>> Bret: IN TONIGHT'S WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO SEGMENT, NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE CASE OF AN
ELITE MILITARY OPERATOR ACCUSED
OF KILLING A TALIBAN BOMB MAKER.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN AS THE UPDATE.
>> THE U.S. ARMY CHARGED WITH
ALLEGED MURDER A DECORATED
GREENBERET WHO ADMITTED TO
KILLING A DETAINEE WITH FOX
NEWS'S BRET BAIER.
>> DID YOU KILL THE BOMB MAKER?
>> YES.
>> HE WAS A U.S. SPECIAL FORCES
SOLDIER ATTACHED TO A MARINE
UNIVERSITY WHO FACED HEAVY
FIGHTING IN FEBRUARY 2010.
WHEN HE APPLIED FOR A JOB AT THE
CIA HE ACKNOWLEDGED KILLING A
TALIBAN MEMBER FOR PLANTING A
BOMB THAT KILLED TWO MARINES.
>> YOU OFFERED UP THESE DETAILS
AT THE CIA?
>> YES.
>> THAT'S WHERE IT ALL STARTED?
>> PRETTY MUCH.
>> ACCORDING TO A SENIOR
DEFENSIVE OFFICIAL, HE TOLD THE
CIA HE KILLED THE MAN OFF-BASE
AND PUT IT IN A PIT AND BURNED
IT.
HE TOLD FOX NEWS I MADE A KNOWN
ENGAGEMENT WITH A KNOWN
COMBATANT.
GOLDSTEIN SAID FOLLOWING THE
BOMB MARKER'S RELEASE, HE
TRACKED HIM DOWN AND KILLED HIM.
>> YOU HAD A LAW ENFORCEMENT
MIND SET?
>> THERE ARE LIMITS HOW LONG WE
COULD HOLD GUYS.
THESE ARE ENEMY COMBATANTS.
THESE ARE TALIBAN.
THESE ARE BAD DUDES.
WE WOULD PULL THEM BUT NOT HAVE
ANY PLACE TO HOLD THEM.
WE WOULD LET THEM BACK AND THEY
WOULD CAUSE TERROR TO THE
COMMUNITY.
>> THE ARMY REOPENED THE
INVESTIGATION BASED ON NEW
EVIDENCE THAT INCLUDE THE
GREENBERET'S PUBLIC STATEMENTS.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATED THE ARMY'S ORIGINAL
HANDLING OF THE CASE WHICH DID
NOT FIND ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
PROSECUTE GOLDSTEIN.
HUNTER A FORMER MARINE
CHAMPIONED GOLDSTEIN'S CASE AND
WROTE THE FOLLOWING LETTER:
I
>> WHAT IS IT LIKE GOING FROM
WAR HERO TO ACCUSED WAR
CRIMINAL?
>> ANGRY.
>> NO, IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY
PAINFUL.
AND VERY DIFFICULT OVER THE LAST
YEAR, EVERYONE WHO SERVED WITH
ME STOOD BY ME.
AND SO, IT'S OVER.
IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON.
>> AND GOLDSTEIN ADMITTED
KILLING A MAN IN COLD BLOOD ON
TELEVISION, THE ARMY
INVESTIGATORS HAD NO CHOICE BUT
TO OPEN THE CASE.
HE SAID HE HAD TO RELEASE THE
ALLEGED TALIBAN BOMB MAKER.
BUT THOSE TO WHOM I SPOKE AT THE
PENTAGON SAID HE HAD A CHOICE